ينضم الي الان من الخرطوم معتصم عبد
القادر حسن المستشار في الاكاديميه العليا
لدراسات الامنيه الاستراتيجيه مرحبا بك
معنا السيد معتصم في هذه التغطيه المفتوحه
على الجزيره في تقديرك لماذا هذا النسق
المتسارع للاشتباكات والتطورات الميدانيه
في جبهات مختلفه في الخرطوم
مرحبا بكم شكرا على الاستضافه
اولا
بالامس كانت هنالك هدنه يبدو ان
ميليشيا دعم السريع المتمرده استغلتها ليس
في العمليات الحربيه وانما في تجميع
صفوفها في اماكن معينه من ولايه الخرطوم
وهذا يعتبر في حد ذاته خرق لما تم الاتفاق
عليه لان في الهدنه لا يمكن تحريك اي قوات
عسكريه من موقعي الى اخر الامر الاخر انا
اعتقد ان المدخل الى حل الاشكاليه
السودانيه من خلال منبر جده هو مدخل خاطئ
اساوى ما بين قوات الدعم السريع المتمرده
وما بين القوات المسلحه الشرعيه وما بين
الدوله السودانيه وهذا جعل من هذه هذا
المنبر لا لا
يعمل لا يعمل له اي اليات كي يقف على
الواقع في الارض مع ان الواقع في الارض في
خروقات
النتيجه لعدم صياح الدعم السريع لكل الهدن
السابقه واختراقه المستمر لها سوى كان
الهجوم على القوات المسلحه السودانيه او
كان بتجميع قواته ومحاولات الالتفاف حول
معسكرات القوات المسلحه السودانيه المسلحه
السودانيه لم تبادر بخلق اي هدنه معارك
اليوم معارك شرسه ولاول مره الجيش
السوداني ينتقل من مرحله الدفاع لانه كان
باستمرار يحاول ان يجنب المدنيين امثل هذه
المعارك ولكنه الان انتقل الى مرحله
هجوميه من كافه المحاور وانا اعتقد ان هذه
المساله قد تضع نهايه سريعه لهذا التمرد
طيب يعني السيد معتصم كان هناك حديث في
الامس عن هدنه وصفت بالاكثر صمودا تقول
بان قوات الدعم السريع استغلتها في تجميع
القوى والان يتم الحديث اذا عن مرحله
جديده وصفتها بالهجوميه للجيش السوداني هل
تعتقد بان ربما الوساطه
تتدخل من جديد لاعلاني هدنه جديده خاصه
وان هناك كذلك الكثير من التحركات
الدبلوماسيه من بينها ما يعقد في جيبوتي
اليوم من اجل محاوله حللت هذه الازمه في
اطار الايجاد
كما ذكرت لك اشكاليه الوساطه بما تحاول
المساواه بين القوات الشرعيه قوات الشعب
السوداني ومن خلفها قياده الدوله
السودانيه وما بين قوه متمرده خرجت على
هذه الشرعيه هذه الاشكاليه الاساسيه اذا
لم ينظر الى المساله السودانيه بطريقه
مختلفه بعيدا عن ان قوات الدعم الشريحه هي
قوات
للقوات المسلحه السودانيه لن تحل هذه
المشكله هذه قوات متمرده وهذه القوات
بالاضافه الى تبوردها انتهكت حرمات
المواطنين السودانيين في كافه اوجه
الانتهاك فلابد قبل يعني منذ بدايه هذه
الازمه منذ بدايه هذه الازمه والتي تدخل
قريبا الشهرين كان هناك دائما ربما كانت
هذه هي الاليه في التفاوض بين الطرفين
سواء تلك التي بداتها
اوساط مختلفه متفرقه في البدايه ثم انتقلت
الى الوساطه الامريكيه السعوديه والتي ادت
الى مجموعه من الهدن او حتى ربما الحديث
عن
ايجاد حل ضمن الايجاد او حتى الاتحاد
الافريقي كمظله اكبر
نعم بالامس السيد الرئيس البرهان اوضح
للسيده الرئيس الاتحاد الافريقي بانه اذا
كانت هنالك
مشكله
عبري يجب ان تخرج هذه القوات المتمرده
ويجب ان تخرج الاجنبيه التي استعانت بها
من بقايا الحرب الليبيه ومن الدول الغربي
الجلوس مع هذه القوات المتمرده فيه منبر
جده كان جلوسا غير مباشر الجلوس هنالك كل
هنالك اعترافا او جلوسا مباشرا قوات الدعم
تم حلها بقرار من مجلس السياده وتم مصادره
ممتلكاتها وهي الان مجموعه من الفلول من
هنا وهناك سوف يتعامل
مع السوداني به
اء غطاء اليوم اذا استمرت انا اعتقد ان
هذه المعركه الان جغرافيا تضيق المساحات
على قوات الدعم السريع وتتجه المعرفه الى
وسط طيب ما الذي جعلك تقول بان هذه مرحله
جديده يبداها الجيش السوداني من اجل انهاء
هذه الازمه ما هي المؤشرات التي اعتمدتها
عليها في قراءتك
الصراط التي اعتمدت عليها ان هنالك نجاحات
ميدانيه تتحقق الان هناك تقهر لقوات الدعم
السريعه المتمرده الان المحور الغربي
مقفول تماما على قوات الدعم السريع كي
تهرب منه غربا ويتم حصارها من الشمال الى
الجنوب ومن الجنوب الى الشمال ومن الشرق
الى الغرب والمحور الغربي مغفور تماما لن
يتبقى لها اي فرصه لاي امداد او اي فرصه
لاي مناورات او لاي اعمال عسكريه الجيش
السوداني للفترات السابقه مراعاه للهدنه
مراعاه للوساطات ومراعاه للمدنيين كان
يعمل على ان لا يهاجم القوات الدعم بكامل
قوته ولكن كما ذكر مراسليك الان الجيش
السوداني الان يعمل بكامل قوته للانتهاء
من هذه
الازمه لعوده الحياه الطبيعيه في السودان
الى اي مدى تعتقد بان هذه المهمه ستكون
سهله بالنسبه للجيش السوداني خاصه واننا
نعلم بان
قوات الدعم السريع وايضا الجيش السوداني
يتجمعون في اماكن اهله بالسكان ربما هو
الذي ادى الى اطاله هذه الازمه بحسب ما
سمع من الطرفين خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
المعارك التي المناطق التي تدور فيها
المعارك الان اغلب السكان اخلوها الى
مناطق وراسها كان في اخلوها الى اطراف
الخرطومه واخلوها الى الولايات واخلوها
الى جمهوريه مصر انا اعتقد ان الان هذه
المرحله لن تعود الى الوراء مره اخرى
والقوات المسلحه السودانيه سوف تستمل
هذا الا الى ارتبط هذه القوات ويرتبط
الجهات التي تتقدم بوساطاتها ان هذه قوات
متمرده يجب ان تخرج
طوعا عن الجميع يعلم وانا اعتقد ان
الوساطه خصوصا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
التي تقول انها تراقب هذه العمليات بواسطه
الاقمار الصناعيه تعمل تعلم تماما ان
الدعم السريع لا يمتلك اي مقرات ولا يمتلك
اي قواعد وانما يكون قواته تتمركز في
المواقع المدنيه يجب اخراج هذه القوات من
المواقع المدنيه اذا اخرجت هذه القوات من
المواقع المدنيه سواء كان بالهدنه الحرب
تكون انتهت واذا لم تخرج سوف يخرجها الجيش
السوداني بالهجوم مثل هجوم اليوم